politicians across the aisle in the
united states have gone after elon musk
for a while now somehow we've condemned
success in the united states elon musk
is one of the great innovators one of
the great problem solvers and
entrepreneurs of our lifetime he not
only built paypal but he's also built
tesla solarcity and of course spacex and
so as we watch the geopolitical conflict
between russia and ukraine play out we
are watching is elon musk step in and
save the day once again now of course i
don't think elon musk or anyone else
around him would say that elon musk is
solving problems at the geopolitical
scale what he is doing is he's
contributing help when it's most needed
and so what we saw was that the vice
prime minister of ukraine went ahead and
asked elon musk to send any sort of help
that he could he wanted to provide
ukraine with startling stations and to
address sane russians to stand of course
elon responded very quickly and said
starling service is now active in
ukraine more terminals are in route now
of course all the haters all the critics
they said this is just a marketing stunt
elon musk is simply grabbing attention
he's not actually going to help well
here's proof that he actually ended up
sending those starlink terminals and
multiple people within ukraine now have
access to the internet we can see them
unpacking them and installing them we
can even see the klitschko brothers
going ahead and saying look we got our
starlink terminals as well this again
being a company that was started back in
2001 or so and went ahead and built an
entire constellation of satellites to
beam the internet down whether you're in
a rural area whether you simply want
faster internet or you're in the middle
of a geopolitical conflict it actually
ends up being pretty helpful now of
course what we can see is that starlink
is not only up and running we can see
that the download and upload speeds are
incredibly fast it's reliable internet
and in a time where more and more people
need access to information and
communication tools this ends up being
quite helpful but of course that doesn't
come without pressure anytime that elon
musk does anything there's people around
the world that go ahead and critique
them that end up applying more and more
pressure and so what we can see is two
tweets that elon had where he said not
only is starlink the only non-russian
communication system that's still
working in some parts of ukraine it's
got a high probability of being targeted
please use with caution and then on top
of that he said that multiple
governments that are not ukraine should
block russian news sources they're not
going to do that unless at gunpoint
sorry to be a free speech absolutist so
ultimately elon musk proving once again
why he's one of the great entrepreneurs
of all time elon musk stepping in doing
his small part to help he doesn't have
all the answers he doesn't have all the
solutions but he does have enough tools
enough people and enough companies to
help push forward progress for humanity
and to see it in a moment of
geopolitical conflict like this is
pretty incredible i'm a fan of eon and i
think more and more people will become
one over time too hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time